on a parlé de femmes résistantes
féministe guerrière aviatrice et vous
savez ce qui manquait à cette chaîne une
vidéo sur l'esclavagé aux états unis et
sur une femme qui luttent contre ça
c'est ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui
avec harriet tubman araminte à ross est
né esclave aux aventures de 1820 dans le
maryland
sa grand-mère était arrivé d'afrique sur
un navire négrier sa mère était
cuisinière son père travailler sur une
tentation elle avait huit frères et
soeurs mais séparé très jeunes de trois
de ses soeurs vendu à un autre
propriétaire il était courant de séparer
les fratries dans le système
esclavagiste son petit frère est menacé
d'être vendu également mais sa mère
résiste avec tant de violence que le
propriétaire renonce finalement à la
vente à l'âge de 5 ou 6 ans elle est
louée pour surveiller le bébé et faire
les travaux de couture d'une femme me
suzanne où elle est victime de violence
physique quotidienne elles portent
plusieurs couches de vêtements pour se
protéger des coups de fouet elle est
ensuite employé par plusieurs
propriétaires comme pose de pièges à
rats esclaves dans les champs
vendeuse dans une mercerie en 1834 alors
qu'elle était moins de la tentative de
fuite d'un autre esclave
elle reçoit un poids de 2 livres en
pleine tête qui le déclenche des
évanouissements aider crise de
convulsions jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
développant une forte croyance et cette
époque elle interprète ces crises comme
des signes divins l'incitant à se
révolter dans la lignée de moïse
libérant les esclaves d'égypte vers
cette époque elle est une jeune
adolescente et décide de prendre le
prénom de sa mère harriet en 1844 elle
épouse john coleman un homme noir libre
mais son mariage n'est pas reconnue par
la loi est elle restée ce cadre elle
rêve de s'enfuir vers le nord mais son
mari estiment qu'ils sont bien où ils
sont les menaces de la dénoncer à son
maître
quelque peu refroidi par ce manque de
compréhension elle reste donc jusqu'à la
mort de son maître en 1849
là elle n'attend pas d'être vendus et
s'enfuit le réseau qui lui permet de
passer les états sans être retrouvés se
nomme le underground le chemin de fer
clandestin
il s'agit d'un réseau de membres du
mouvement abolitionniste et docks
workers chaque fugitif est aidée d'un
chef de train qui dissimule ses
passagers dans des caches des maisons
ali elle passe la ligne mason dixon qui
sépare les états du sud et du nord et
s'installe finalement à philadelphie
quand je découvris que j'avais franchi
cette ligne
je regardais mes mains pour voir si
j'étais la même personne il y avait une
telle gloire surtout le soleil est
apparu comme l'or à travers les arbres
et sur les champs et je me sentais comme
si j'étais au paradis
à philadelphie a travaillé durant un an
avant de commencer ses missions de
passeuse son premier sauvetage via sa
nièce et ses deux fils est toujours
esclave dans le maryland
j'étais une étrangère dans un monde
étrange
mon père ma mère mes frères et soeurs et
amis étaient au marineland
mais j'étais libre et il devait être
libre eux aussi elle réussit également à
ramener ses quatre frères dans le nord
mais sa soeur rachel meurent avant que
les autant de la sauver elle effectue
ensuite de nombreux allers-retours
malgré le récent fugitive acte qui
contraignait tous les états
même ceux ayant aboli l esclavage a
participé à la capture des esclaves en
fuite
à cause de ça les routes du chemin de
fer clandestin change et amène désormais
les anciens esclaves au canada plus sûr
elle s'y installe en 1851 dans la petite
ville de sainte-catherine qui compte 500
noir majoritairement d'anciens esclaves
pour 7000 habitants en tant que chef de
réseau du chemin de fer clandestin
elle connaît toutes les routes même les
plus dangereuses telles que le pont
suspendu nécessaires à la traversée des
chutes du niagara
elle n'hésite pas non plus à menacer
d'une arme les fugitifs qui voudraient
relancer
vous serez libres ou mort de 1850 à 1860
elle effectue entre 13 et 19 voyages
entre le sud et le canada
souvent plus de 70 personnes sans jamais
perdre un seul passager
ces sauvetages font d'elle l'une des
plus grandes figures du chemin de fer
clandestin et lui valent le surnom de
black moses moïse noir au début de la
guerre de sécession en 1861
elle rejoint un groupe d'abolitionnistes
en caroline du sud et ils servent comme
cuisinière et infirmières elle aide
aussi à la cartographie des lieux et ont
habitué à parcourir beyrouth la dirige à
partir de 1863 un groupe d'espions et
fournit des conseils lors de la prise de
jacksonville et pour les raids contre
les troupes zelig la guerre prend fin et
l'esclavagé est aboli en 1865
elle s'engage alors dans la lutte contre
le racisme et pour le vote des femmes
elle participe à des conférences sur la
côte est des états unis utilisant son
action et celle de nombreuses autres
femmes pour montrer que tout mérite le
droit de vote
sa biographie est publié de son vivant
par sarah bradford en 1869
c'est qui lui permet de sortir de la
misère
elle se remarie également avec un
vétéran de la guerre de sécession et
s'installe à auburn dans l'état de new
york et adopte une petite fille elle
contribuer à fonder un hospice pour afro
américains âgés et malades dans lequel
elle s'installe à la fin de sa vie et il
meurt le 19 mars 1913 à environ 90 ans
harriet tubman continue d'être honoré
après sa mort elle est enterrée avec les
honneurs militaires plusieurs timbres à
son effigie sont évités amusé dans le
new-jersey doit s'ouvrir en 2020 et un
biopic sur sa vie doit également sortir
cette année
elle est aussi reconnu comme personne
d'importance historique par le
gouvernement canadien
il y en a ce terreau id découvert en
2010 porte son nom le dernier honneur et
pas des moindres devait également avoir
lieu cette année
l'administration de barack obama avait
décidé en 2010 est que harriet man
ornerait désormais les billets de 20
dollars américains malheureusement
étonnamment l'administration de donald
trump est un peu revenu sur la question
autre priorité problèmes de budget le
projet est repoussé à 2028
elle aurait été la troisième femme à
apparaître sur un billet américain est
la première personne noire j'espère que
cet épisode vous a plu j'avais
particulièrement envie de sortir une
vidéo jean todt a bad ass pour la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes du 8 mars
donc voilà c'est fait et bien continuez
de vous renseigner sur des femmes
importantes
et moi je vais continuer de le faire de
mon côté et de vous livrer le résultat
de mes recherches en vidéo
j'ai une liste très longue de femmes à
aborder encore bien sûr en alternant
avec des chroniques de profs et de votre
choix vous retrouverez un chronique de
profs alors à bientôt
comme nous
à
[Musique]
tout est dit
oh